in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brian
and Alisa are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you
welcome welcome where you guys from
Springfield Illinois very cool and here
to do your debt free train yes sir I
love it how much have you paid off
eighty thousand two hundred and four
dollars
very good how long did that take 28
months very very good and your range of
income during that time we started at 79
thousand and with new contracts are up
to 93 thousand
very cool what do you guys do for a
living I am a PE teacher and coach and
I'm a CPA awesome very good so what kind
of debt was the $80,000
we had sixty-five thousand in student
loans eighty five hundred in the car
2500 family loan and 4200 that was our
honeymoon that we put on my credit card
of course you did so what happened 28
months ago we were sitting at home we
were about three months into our
marriage and three months in just both
starting our new jobs and we were bored
and I said let's go out to eat and get a
pizza and she looked at me and said we
don't have any money left in the bank
account to go do that and I was in
disbelief we were going everything the
CPA says we're broke which means were
broke we were putting everything on a
credit card and then at the end the
month using everything in the bank
account to pay off the credit card yeah
when they're teaching you guys
accounting and they teaching me finance
they don't teach personal finance do
they they do not
yeah so it's a different skill set it's
a different it's hard to believe a CPA
would be that broke but a Finance
Manager
I mean a finance major like me I went
broke right so yeah you can do it you
can do it for sure so what happened you
say okay we can't go out for a pizza so
what happens I think the way Bryan
reacted kind of shook me and I was like
something has to change like we can't go
the rest of our lives like this so I did
a Google search and I found you and I
had heard about you so I ordered the
Total Money Makeover and I read it in
two days and I told Bryan I think we
should try this
I wasn't on board as much at first then
we started taking the class and being it
do you want to Financial Peace
University says okay being a teacher
especially we were trying to move back
to the state of Illinois and the way
that education system is there what I
heard the retirement talk and how much
you could have being debt-free it would
just lit me up like I'm ready to go
let's jump on this now okay it's worth
it to live like no one else so later you
can live and give like no one else yes
now that that does fire you up it sure
does very cool so you guys you you you
read the book or you just took off and
went to the class how did that end up I
read the book and then we took FPU
together twice now yeah all right very
cool well it's working for you yes
80,000 bucks paid off in 26 months I
mean when you were sitting there that
night and you couldn't go eat pizza did
you have any idea 26 months later you'd
be free completely free no that's just
that that's pretty cool y'all you guys
went wide open man I mean you ain't
gizelle intense you went for it you you
were going so crazy people had to make
fun of you people make fun of you but
every time we sometimes go out or make a
purchase we'd have some people say well
Dave approve of that so everybody would
kind of all notice we're doing this
right yeah very cool and so you probably
got some cheerleaders out of it when you
finished up everybody Niels oh oh that's
a breslav yes sir a lot of good friends
and family has been very supportive very
proud of us very cool well they should
be I'm proud of you this is very good
very good so what do you tell people the
key is now I mean you've been married
two months you get this crazy book
you're going this crazy class you pay
off eighty thousand bucks in twenty
eight months I mean tell people what is
the key to doing that coming from a CPA
the budget of course and cash envelopes
really made a difference for us because
once we're out of cash we just stopped
or we would look in the envelope and
we'd see what we have left and we'd be
like is that really what we want to do
when we have you know two weeks left in
the month you know it's so easy to do a
value judgment
when you look in there and do that and
go no and it's so easy to say won't one
that's empty we're done it's a cash
spending plan I mean it's a it's a you
know a limit keeps you from overspending
a category and I just it's amazing in
this digital world we live in how
something is analog and primitive is the
envelope system really does help yeah
and the biggest thing for me was
actually getting involved and
communicating with her about where the
money was spinning because before I was
never involved and once we started this
we sat down every month and every time
we made a decent-sized purchase we would
talk about is this we sure we want to
spend it on this so communicating to me
was the biggest thing the biggest help
for our relationship absolutely if you
do that the rest of your life that'll be
a big help in wealth building there's a
high correlation between quality
communication in the marriage and the
ability to build wealth all the stats
show us that all the research so very
cool you guys very proud of Yannick you
excellent excellent job now we're gonna
give you a copy of Chris Hogan's number
one bestseller retire inspired because
that's the next step build wealth build
wealth build wealth and be able to be
just outrageously generous because
you've got outrageous amounts of money
it's a very cool thing well very cool so
all right Bryan and Alisa Springfield
Illinois $80,000 paid off in 28 months
making 79 to 93 count it down let's hear
a debt free scream 3
way to go you two well done proud of you
very well done very well done hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common